which NBA rookie needs their own show
grd dick he's got the swag Grady dick
he's got Charisma Ling down on draft day
I'm going say grd dick he lives a crazy
life I saw him in the Don's music video
grd dick has high energy great Charisma
he has to start his own podcast
definitely grd dick he's just a sick guy
I think Grady dick has a good
personality for it also a handsome face
so good for the camera why not grd dick
is the most enthusiastic rookie dick
Grady obviously number one gry dick
right come on Dick should have his own
show Gren dick probably gry dick gry
dick gry dick gry dick gry dick gry dick
dick gry dick gry dick gry you need to
make a show man we love you Toronto
loves you
hey all right y'all ask for
it